why couldn't the pirate play cards
because he was standing on the deck okay
it's not my best work but following
quantum breaks released this week on
Xbox one and PC it's now been reported
that people who pirate the game will
receive a rather unique form of
punishment I'm Lucy and welcome to this
stolen GameSpot news update reddit user
disaster explains but if the game thinks
you may be running a pirated copy it
gives main character Jack Joyce an
eyepatch this doesn't seem to give Jack
any new abilities but being a time
pirate is kind of cool I guess and
that's totally a game that I would play
in an FAQ about the Windows 10 version
of quantum break developer remedy T's -
this form of pirate punishment Jack
rocks like a pirate
DRM might have accidentally triggered
Remini explained to avoid this issue
make sure you're logged in to your
Microsoft account before starting the
game and also maybe don't steal it you
might remember that remedy did this with
its last game Alan Wake what do you
think of this kind of punishment let me
know in the comments below or come find
me on Twitter I'm at Lisa James games
for all your Jack Joyce needs keeping
GameSpot